love is a quest for truth truth in
relation to something quite precise what
kind of world does one see when one
experiences it from the point of view of
two and not one what is the world like
when it is experienced developed and
lived from the point of view of
difference and not identity the
Declaration of love marks the transition
from chance to Destiny and that's why it
is so perilous and so burdened with a
kind of horrifying stage fright
love is an existential project to
construct a world from a dissentered
point of view other than that of my mere
impulse to survive or reaffirm my own
identity
to love is to struggle Beyond Solitude
with everything in the world that can
animate existence
love is maybe the hardest thing in the
world